en esta ocasión tengo la integral del
coseno de 5x / elevado al seno de 5x
diferencial de x y como ya tenemos un
poco más de experiencia con esto
entonces seguramente me vas a decir
vamos a resolverlo por un cambio de
variable y en este caso me cambio de
variable va a ser igual al seno de 5x y
es igual al seno de 5x porque es la
potencia de la función exponencial y
bueno ya que tenemos nuestro cambio de
variable vamos a sacar la derivada de
eeuu con respecto a x dvd x es igual a 5
que es la derivada de lo que está dentro
la derivada de 5x por el coseno de 5x
que es la derivada del seno y esto sí lo
escribimos en su forma diferencial nos
va a quedar la diferencial de eeuu es
igual a 5 veces el coseno de 5x y darse
cuenta que es casi lo que tenemos aquí
aquí ya tenemos el coseno de 5x
diferencial de x diferencial de x de x
no se me va a olvidar y bueno si se dan
cuenta aquí ya casa
tenemos la diferencial de v lo único que
nos hace falta es un 5 por lo tanto me
voy a tomar el atrevimiento de poner
aquí un 5 y recuerden que si pongo
dentro de la integral un 5 entonces
tengo que poner afuera del integral un
quinto es decir el inverso
multiplicativo este es mi 1 fantasma
porque 5 por un quinto me da 1 y
recuerda que multiplicar por 1 pues no
es hacer nada por lo tanto pues no estoy
haciendo nada a esta integral
sin embargo date cuenta de la
importancia de este 5 porque este 5 ya
me completa la diferencial de 1 y ya con
esto entonces puedo hacer mi cambio de
variable
entonces me va a quedar un quinto y lo
voy a poner con el mismo color un quinto
de color magenta que multiplica a quien
va a multiplicar a la integral de y
bueno todo lo que está aquí arriba lo
que está de azul es la diferencia del de
15 veces el coste no de 5x de x habíamos
dicho que es la diferencia
por lo tanto arriba me queda la
diferencia entre el elevado al seno de
5x pero el seno de 5x en nuestro cambio
de variable
y por lo tanto me queda elevado a la 1 y
perfecto ya hice mi cambio de variable
ahora la pregunta es ustedes saben cómo
ser suelo esta integral seguramente lo
primero que me vas a decir es que esta
es la integral de una función
exponencial pero aquí hay un problema la
exponencial está dividiendo entonces voy
a escribirlo de la siguiente manera para
que se vea de una manera mucho más
sencilla de resolver esta integral esta
expresión es lo mismo que un quinto del
color magenta que multiplica a la
integral amarilla de elevado a la menos
un diferencial de v lo que hice fue
utilizar las leyes de los exponentes y
pasar la potencia como negativa porque
estaba dividiendo pero en esta ocasión
la función exponencial ya no está
dividiendo la función exponencial está
multiplicando al diferencial de uno sin
embargo ahora date cuenta de que el
problema es resolver la integral de
elevado la menos
o diferencial de eeuu y sin embargo la
integral que yo me sé de memoria es la
integral de el elevado diferencial de v
aquí tenemos un problema con un signo
por lo tanto voy a hacer un segundo
cambio de variable y aquí está lo más
importante de este vídeo voy a hacer un
segundo cambio de variable el cual va a
ser w es igual a menos
y entonces la derivada de w con respecto
a es igual a menos 1 en su forma
diferencial me queda que de w es igual a
menos de eeuu y bueno ya que tenemos
esto lo que nos hace falta aquí es un
signo de menos porque aquí tenemos a w y
nos hace falta la de w pero de w es
igual a menos de v por lo tanto nos hace
falta un signo de menos que lo voy a
poner aquí y si lo pongo aquí entonces
también lo tengo que poner afuera porque
recuerden que menos x menos me da más y
entonces no afecta a esta igualdad de
hecho también hay otra forma de ponerlo
lo podríamos escribir de la siguiente
manera si yo pongo un menos uno aquí y
también pongo un menos uno al lado de la
diferencial de uno y es otra vez el uno
fantasma porque menos uno por menos uno
me da uno positivo y ahora sí que tengo
tengo que todo esto va a ser de w y me
queda
elevado a la w por lo tanto vamos a
sustituir todo lo que tengo aquí
haciendo mi nuevo cambio de variable es
decir mi segundo cambio de variable por
lo tanto haciendo el cambio de variable
esto me queda menos un quinto porque es
menos uno por un quinto y después pongo
mi integral de amarillo y me queda
elevado a la nueva variable que tengo es
decir el elevado a la w entonces me
queda elevado a la w y esto x menos dv
es decir la diferencial de w por lo
tanto al final me queda menos un quinto
de la integral de ea la w de w la cual
se ha convertido en una integral muy
sencilla de resolver esta integral es la
integral de la exponencial que siempre
hemos resuelto por lo tanto esto es
igual a menos un quinto lo voy a poner
todo con sus respectivos colores este
vídeo me está quedando súper colorido y
es que me gustan los vídeos con muchos
colores porque así nunca nos perdemos
entonces me queda menos un quinto de
elevado a la w más una constante de
integración ya resolví mi integral ahora
lo que hay que hacer es regresar todo el
lenguaje del
original es decir hacer la sustitución
hacia atrás por lo tanto me va a quedar
menos un quinto menos de verde un quinto
de magenta de amarillo y w era igual a
menos y por lo tanto en lugar de w
voy a poner menos 1 ya esto hay que
sumarle una constante de integración lo
que estoy haciendo es mi primera
sustitución hacia atrás y todavía hay
que regresarnos más hacia atrás porque
recuerden que mi variable original en la
cual estaba escrita ese problema era la
variable x porque recuerden que hice una
doble sustitución y por lo tanto tengo
que hacer una doble sustitución hacia
atrás entonces vamos a sustituir en
términos de x y entonces con todos los
colores posibles me va a quedar menos un
quinto que multiplica a elevado a la
menos
pero es igual al seno de 5x por lo tanto
me queda menos un quinto de elevado a la
menos seno de 5x ya todo esto hay que
sumarle una constante de integración y
justo ya con esto logramos resolver el
ejercicio que teníamos en un principio
pero eso
y no vayas a olvidar nunca a regresar
todo a términos de la variable original
ahora bien seguramente y aunque no
quiero entrar en un tema de debate
pueden existir personas que me digan que
esto puede salir de una manera mucho más
rápida haciendo solamente un cambio de
variable por lo tanto vamos a ver un
método alternativo o un segundo método
para resolver esta integral
entonces acabo de escribir la integral
con la que empezamos y bueno esto es lo
mismo que la integral de coseno de 5x
que multiplica a elevado a la menos 95 x
diferencial de x y ojo estoy poniéndome
exponente negativo porque estoy
utilizando las leyes de los exponentes
recuerden que los exponentes de una
variable que estaba dividiendo pueden
escribirse negativas cuando pasan
multiplicando y bueno entonces sacamos
el siguiente cambio de variable
agarremos otra vez a la potencia de la
función exponencial y me queda que es
igual a menos de 95 x idv es igual a
menos 5 veces conocer 95 x de x por lo
tanto aquí me hace falta un 5 lo voy a
poner afuera voy a multiplicar por menos
un quinto y todo esto me da el 1
y ahora sí voy a hacer el cambio de
variable me va a quedar menos un quinto
de la integral y bueno lo primero que
quiero que vean es que menos 50 95 x de
x es la diferencial de eeuu y fue justo
por esta razón que yo multiplique por el
menos 5 con esta constante ajuste la
integral para que ahora sí menos 5 095
xd xd de déu y por otro lado tengo el
exponencial elevada a la menos 35 x que
es y recuerden que fue mi cambio de
variable y este cambio de variable me
ayuda bastante porque ya sabemos
resolver esta integral este es la
integral que siempre está en los libros
acerca del exponencial y tiene como
solución lo que habíamos comentado hace
rato esto tiene como solución menos un
quinto ojo no olviden nunca la constante
menos un quinto que va a multiplicar ha
elevado a la u más c y ahora si ya que
solucionamos esta integral perfecto pues
entonces vamos a hacer el cambio de
variable hacia atrás la sustitución
hacia atrás es igual al menos 95 x y
entonces me queda menos un quinto de él
95 x + c y llegamos al mismo resultado
solamente que esta vez haciendo un
cambio de variable al final si quieres
hacer el primer método o el segundo
método es decir haciendo una o dos
cambios de variables es lo mismo lo más
importante es que llegues a la solución
y que te sientas cómodo con el método
que vas a utilizar